[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen blog
meine damen und herren
da liegt juli von allen guten geistern
verlassen freunde das hier ist ein
fenster und das macht dann ist das auf
man riecht man frische luft stinkt das
hier ist ein sessel wenn man sich da
einsetzt kann man leben genommen
die bücher das hier ist in verschiedene
bücher und dieses buch gibt einem live
weißes buch heißt einfach live und der
hessischen kollegen dafür dass du krank
bist siehst du eigentlich wirklich recht
gut aus auf jeden fall hat jule gerade
in dem buch ein bild wird sich selbst
gefunden konnte seine brusthaare also
sieht julia in dem buch haus und so
sieht sie jetzt die echte jule mal krank
und deswegen wenn nötig muss jetzt auch
zur apotheke bewegen geld abheben und
dann gehen wir auch noch einkaufen aber
jetzt gehen wir erstmal zur apotheke
heute es war der erste tag seit zwei
monaten das passieren der nordsee nicht
komplett am sonne scheinen dass überall
wo sogar wolken aus dem hund juli muss
erstmal einen kukksi in den see und
apotheke abholen das ding ist halt viel
taugt mir gehts doch so ein bisschen
schlecht habe jetzt gerade so krass hals
schmerzt aber ich habe kein fieber mehr
uns aber juli samstags einfach eine
mittagspause von viereinhalb stunden
dann haben und etwas zu essen
[Musik]
jelinek
viereinhalb stunden mittagspause sind
vergangen ist es gerade 17 uhr und wir
versuchen jetzt unser glück an der
apotheke
juli sind wieder zu hause angekommen da
es ja schon mal auf jeden fall war mir
eigentlich jetzt gerade den ganzen tag
unterwegs wir wollten eigentlich nur die
apotheke gehen ein bisschen was besorgen
weil ich jude irgendwie mit meiner
krankheit angesteckt habe gehe und mir
hat noch einkaufen und dann haben wir
halt irgendwie gesehen dass noch voll
viele freunde aus den letzten jahren die
wir hier kennengelernt haben auch noch
heute angekommen sind mit der fähre
deswegen haben wir dann noch alle
begrüßt da war noch alles anders essen
was trinken und ja jetzt ist es auch
schon wieder halb abend wo soll ich mein
leben auf jeden fall sehen ist bereits
im titel eingeblendet es geht zu weit
oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung
ich will das ganze eigentlich gar nicht
mehr so krass ernst verpacken allerdings
sind wir den letzten tagen einige
situationen aufgefallen wo ich mir
selber gedacht haben menschen nicht
gesehen nicht abstoßen also ich meine
ich veröffentliche videos auf youtube
ich zeige mein gesicht ich poste bilder
auf instagram ich mache dies ich machte
das also mein leben ist irgendwie der
öffentlichkeit gewidmet und ich bin eine
person des öffentlichen interesses das
heißt damit tatsächlich auch dass leute
die einfach mich auf der straße sehen
mich fotografieren können und ich habe
kein recht an diesem bild und es fakt
halt echt schon hart ab manchmal wenn
leute einfach einmal fotografieren
heimlich und wandern nichts gegen sagen
kann es gab schon einige enge
situationen so zum beispiel war ich mit
dem kollegen bei ikea und dann steht auf
allerdings und junge auf der straße
stellt sich vor uns formelauto eine
handball macht einfach bilder von uns im
auto nicht denken dass auch die
irgendwelche hobbys es gab schon 45
situationen wo mich irgendwelche essens
die verdammten nach autogrammen gefragt
haben
es standen schon kinder bei uns im
treppenhaus also es gab wirklich einige
situationen oder die ich so richtig
öffentlich noch nie wirklich geredet
habe ich dem ganzen halt irgendwie eine
plattform geben wollte den letzten tagen
und heute so einiges wieder fahren wo
ich dachte immer das nicht anspricht
damit geht das immer weiter und es hat
echt schon rad ab das möchte ich
allerdings sagen dass ich kein mitleid
möchte oder irgendwas
es ist nicht damit alle in die
kommentare schreiben von dem leid das
ist wirklich nur ein ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz ganz kleiner teil der
leute die mich wirklich auf der straße
ansprechen die ich jetzt gerade hiermit
meine und die meisten leute sind
wirklich so unglaublich korrekt und man
kann sich mit den cool unterhalt und das
sind nette leute mit netten eltern
allerdings ich berichte mal wir befinden
uns hier gerade an der nordsee und hier
sind natürlich auch viele familien mit
ihren kindern weil halt strand und viele
freizeitaktivitäten und so weiter und so
fort liegt dann halt auch nahe dass
einige von diesen kindern mich von
youtube kennen ich weiß nicht warum man
mich schaut aber hier auf jeden fall mal
ganz kurz situation numero uno wir waren
gestern essen in einem restaurant und es
war alles super so ich war halt
unglaublich krank und es hat bei mir
halt auch wirklich angesehen da kamen
also zweimal so eine truppe von leuten
die halt bilder machen wollen das waren
halt eben welche kinder die waren so
14.15 würde ich sagen die haben
vielleicht noch nicht so ein richtiges
verständnis dafür allerdings kamen dann
halt eltern die wirklich gesehen haben
hey mir geht es gerade nicht so gut die
kinder richtet mega freundlich waren und
mich halt angeguckt haben halt mein sohn
luca wie viele videos folgen wir kurz
ein foto machen ich sage also voll am
husten und halt voll am schwitzen ich
weil ich hat das fieber die letzten vier
tage aber ich habe trotzdem gesagt ja
haye klar das ist ein foto macht und
versucht irgendwie freue mich zu gucken
dann kommt die muster ahnung kommt also
voller an mich ran so wer bist du
eigentlich bist du wer doch rühmt ist
und dann habe ich einfach gesagt danke
der nachfrage ich bin luca und dann sind
judo dich halt gang aus dem restaurant
100 setzt sich diese frau auf meinen
stuhl wo ich saß nachzubauen sie als
auch alle fotos bitte mache bin ich
jetzt auch werbe übte einfach eine
erwachsene dame so das ist da falsch
gelaufen die kinder dann aber wirklich
sehr sehr freuen
die koaltion nummer dass wir diesen
restaurant aufgestanden sind nach hause
gehen wollte wurde mir von einem jungen
mehr
mein name geschrieben anstatt dass er
also an kam und mir einfach so leise
gesagt hey du kannst ein foto machen hat
der durchs ganze ressort mich in lucka
hasloop ich denke es war nur so dicker
kommt doch einfach 100 frag mich was du
möchte natürlich der junge war wie ein
war der juli
okay da war 8 oder so aber trotzdem
finde ich dass man irgendwie so einen
gewissen anstand haben sollte und dass
auch ein achtjähriger begreifen sollte
wenn er etwas von dem möchte sondern zu
mir her kommen
also ich weiß nicht was dann mit der
erziehung los war aber naja das für mich
war es halt echt stressig so ich meine
ich luft nach oben mit fieber und hatte
gratis sondern abgefuckte situation und
dann geht das ganze restaurant auf mich
aufmerksam weil so ein junger meinen
namen schreiben aber situationen nummer
33 die bereits gesagt waren julia und
ich heute eigentlich die ganzen tag
unterwegs waren bei der apotheke und
haben doch heute getroffen weil mit dem
was essen was trinken einkaufen und sind
halt jetzt wieder zu hause und natürlich
habe ich auch heute wieder irgendwie so
weiß ich nicht zehn bilder oder
irgendwie so gemacht mit welchen leuten
die ich getroffen habe und das war
wirklich alles cool natürlich sind da
zwischendurch leute dabei die ein und
nehmen sie ein bisschen verfolgen
einiger zeit so dann kommt natürlich
darauf an dass offen
wenn du was fangen möchtest kommt gern
sowie hin so ich bin da echt eigentlich
relativ offen für alle also offen für
bilder und autogramme und videos und
sparen möchten und so hey jude
hallo es auf jeden fall so dass
jugendliche uns gerade gedacht haben hey
und das jetzt mal nach hause gehen und
dann wurden wir von fans verfolgt und
ich bin dann halt jemand der einfach
weitergeht weil ich habe oft genug
leuten gesagt verfolgt mich bis nicht
wenn ich irgendwo bin ich pack das echt
einfach nur ab und die haben mich hätten
wir weiter verfolgt und ich dachte halt
an einem gewissen punkt ok ab hier die
ihr könnt auch recht einfach mal gehen
und auch wenn sie hier sehen ob wir
wohnen hier nur noch für drei tagen oder
so wenn sie wissen wo wir wollen das war
ja wissen eh schon voll viele dann ist
es mir auch egal
also ist jetzt nicht so wie wenn jemand
in köln weiß wo ich wohne oder in
bielefeld oder so auf jeden fall war es
allerdings so dass wir hier wieder zu
hause waren und ging es um die ecke in
unsere wohnung rein die wir hier
gemietet haben wir uns dann höre ich
diese kinder rufen hey das war kontrast
der wohnt auch da auf jeden fall war es
dann halt so dass nicht unten auf
toilette war und julia oben kurz im bett
und das fenster offen und sag mal was
die gesagt haben
irgendwie glaube vier kinder und ich
glaube er war sogar auch noch mit buy
und die haben gesagt ja das war wirklich
die rechte bekommen sich ja haben das
von einer klinik ist das hat ebene ist
hause sondern ein seit jahren bekannter
zu viert für den pingel kommen ja dann
werden wir dann nach dem foto fragen und
djane wirklich die ganze vor dem haus
auch halt so lautet ich hab das alles
kann dort ja das ist halt auch so das
ding ich weiß ich hab die extra so laut
reden aber auch so als wir hier vor der
haustür waren und die stadt wirklich so
hundert meter hinter uns haben nie so
richtig gut gespielt dort etwa der live
den fragen gegangen sind meine diese
lasst uns einfach morgen noch mal
herkommen
bei mir ist gesagt ja alter also das war
halt wirklich zu den letzten 24 stunden
die situation wo ich mir das gerade
gedacht hey das muss ich einfach kurz
noch mal sagen ich habe letztes jahr
schon mal ein video gemacht wo wir genau
das gleiche problem haben da wurden uns
briefe geschickt die auf einmal vor der
tür mit einer gewissen form halt noch
süß aber da waren halt trotzdem leute
die irgendwie meine privatsphäre nicht
akzeptiert haben deswegen leute bitte
wenn ihr mich hier trefft oder wenn
nämlich allgemein trefft ich bin immer
bereit dafür ein foto zu machen oder ein
video zu machen ich glaub ich hab das
noch nie abgelehnt außer wirklich wenn
ich gemerkt habe dass ich verfolgt werde
und dass leute meinen namen hinter mir
her schreien oder irgendwelche grenzen
überschreitet oder bei den privatsphäre
nicht akzeptieren ich will überhaupt
nicht um heute so ich meine ich habe mir
das leben selbst ausgesucht ich lade
alle videos hoch wie ich mich zeigen ich
glaube mein leben was ich mache und
natürlich musste mit so etwas umgehen
aber man kann ja einfach mal bitten und
sagen dass die eigene meinung ist und
ich meine das ist halt meine meinung und
ich bin echt bauen auch wenn die kinder
hier die uns verfolgt haben vor 300 400
meter vorhergesagt hatten händler kurzen
foto mache ich mich mit hinterhalten
bilder gemacht alles aber wenn ich jetzt
noch mal sehen sollte sind ja werde ich
dann halt echt ne ansage machen soll ich
find's ok ich ehrlich gesagt
da hinten sind die wolken da hinten sind
die gelb und hier sind die so schwarz
ich bin voll überfordert und da ist ja
ich habe nur ein paar coole leute ich
habe tatsächlich mal wieder vergessen
bevor die gäste an der stelle wird den
heutigen blog jetzt allerdings jetzt
habe ich hier die lampe herunter
geschlagen anderer stelle durch den
heutigen blog jetzt allerdings auch
während meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne mal an leica
ich musste dieses ganze thema einfach
mal ansprechen
[Musik]